rights groups are reporting that Iran is
carrying out a major Crackdown and the
Kurdish town of mahabat the town has
seen intense anti-regime protests in
recent days with people staging sit-ins
and setting up barricades
in videos circulated on social media
overnight gunfire and screaming can be
heard another clip shared by an exiled
Kurdish opposition party claims to show
plain clothes members of the
Revolutionary guard firing into the sky
[Music]
activists say electricity has been cut
and there are unconfirmed reports of
protesters being killed or wounded
for more Mahmoud
co-founder of the NGO Iran human rights
is joining us from right here in Berlin
Mahmoud what are you hearing from
sources about the situation in mahabad
yeah so we have heard that since
yesterday evening a large number of
military people belonging to the
Revolutionary guards and the military
vehicles have entered the city we have
been hearing machine gun basically all
the night they have cut down the
electricity during the night and at the
present moment we don't have any
confirmed reports about the casualties
but it doesn't look good it seems that
the authorities are planning a major
crackdowns and they are very concerned
that it might
result in in human tragedy in the
massacre
do we know anything about the scale of
the government operation in the city at
this point
well
the information they have received is
that the numbers are very large so so it
is also believed that the Iranian
authorities are trying to make this uh
you know Iran protest where all the
country has been standing United against
the regime they want to convert into you
know ethnic issues they have been also
that in lots of a campaign of
misinformation this this information
they're saying that you know they are
going to find the other armed Rebels but
that's not true these are Ordinary
People so I think it's a demonstration
of power spreading fear and killing
people you know so far
378 people have been killed and only on
History the recent days around to 40
people most of them in the Kurdish
regions
in about the 45 seconds we have left
give us a little bit of perspective how
strong is the opposition against Iranian
authorities in Kurdish dominated areas
well it has always been very strong
because the uh in all ethnic regions
both Kurdistan because you know Iranian
regime is uh basically composed of a
small group of the Iranian Society
ruling the whole country and the
repression that has been in the ethnic
regions that Kurdish areas has been much
stronger I mean even stronger than the
rest of country and that that's why the
opposition is also figure people are
very brave and and I think that you know
Islamic Republic has never faced such a
huge crisis in the whole country so they
are trying to do whatever they can to
change because it's going towards the
big change and they are going to do
whatever they can to survive and so we
are also concerned that it might even
start a small war with you know Iraqi
Kurdistan just to get the attention away
from this big what I would say
Revolution going on inside the room
understood uh that was
many many thanks